wir stehen davor dass viele Menschen
hungern werden weil sie nicht mehr
klarkommen die Lebensmittelpreise haben
wir heute auch in den Nachrichten gehört
werden noch mal ansteigen immer weniger
Tafeln haben die Möglichkeit neue
Menschen die in Arm in der Armutsfalle
sind aufzufangen wir als Arche in
Deutschland haben immer mehr Besucher
bei Menschen die jetzt nicht mehr bei
der Tafel genommen werden und Familie
haben kommt zu uns und fragen uns nach
Lebensmitteln nach Unterstützung die
Betriebskosten steigen bis ins
Unermessliche die Politik sicher zwar
ein eine energiebremse zu aber keiner
weiß genau was damit passiert Menschen
fühlen sich allein gelassen mit ihren
Fragen politische Informationen kommen
beim Bürger eher mit großen Fragezeichen
an wir haben Kinder die gehen
ungefrühstückt in die Schulen weil das
Frühstück einfach zu teuer ist ich warne
vor einem Chaos was zum Jahresende
kommen wird ich habe eine Mutter die hat
gerade gesagt ich habe 5 € pro Kind für
Weihnachtsgeschenke und wenn man
Weihnachten nicht mehr seinen Kindern
etwas schenken kann weil wir nicht die
Möglichkeiten wir haben weil Menschen
unverschuldeten Armut geraten können wir
Weihnachten abschaffen und vielleicht
auch die Politik abschaffen die das
gemacht hat
die Politik abschaffen die das gemacht
hat wo ist die Politik die das ändert
ich weiß nicht wo die Politik ist die
das ändert wir haben seit 2001 einen
Armutsbericht und da heißt es damals vor
2001 dass wir 1,2 Millionen Kindern
finanzieller Armut haben heute haben wir
drei Millionen und die Geburten sind
zurückgegangen das heißt die Politik hat
in den letzten Jahren versagt wir
sprechen über Bürgergeld wir sprechen
Überhöhung von Finanzen aber das Geld
kommt beim Kind nicht an warum weil wenn
Geld in die Familien kommen dann sagen
viele die Eltern versaufen das Geld
verrauchen das Geld was vollkommener
Quatsch ist weil würden sie es machen
hätten wir ein gesellschaftliches ganz
anderes Problem das Kind kommt das Geld
kommt beim Kind nicht an weil mit den
Eltern oft Löcher gestopft werden
deswegen fordere ich dass das Geld
direkt beim Kind landet z.B in Form
einer bezahlt dann könnten z.B Kinder
ihre außerschulische Nachhilfe per App
bezahlen das wirklich von den Eltern
abgebucht sondern vom Jobcenter oder wie
auch immer da gibt es einen bestimmtes
Kontingent unser Bildungssystem muss
besser ausgestattet werden es kann nicht
sein dass Kinder die von Hartz IV den
letzten Leben eigentlich schon von
vornherein abgestempelt sind dass sie
ihr Abitur nicht machen können obwohl
sie vielleicht schlau genug sind weil
sie eben in ein oder zwei Fächer nicht
so gut mitkommen und sie sich aber diese
einstündige Nachhilfe pro Woche in der
Schule nicht ausreicht um sie
entsprechend zu fördern wir denken über
Fachkräfte nach die wir aus dem Ausland
importieren und wir befähigen unsere
eigenen Kinder nicht genug wir haben
glaube ich 45.000 Schulabgänger jedes
Jahr die in Schulabschluss nicht
schaffen und das liegt nicht daran dass
die Kinder dumm sind oder sie kommen aus
der bildungsfernschicht sondern sie
brauchen mehr Förderung diese Förderung
die muss man einfach machen und es kann
nicht sein dass in Ballungsgebieten der
Lehrer die eierlegende Wollmilchsau ist
die 25 Kinder der 25 Kinder pro Klasse
hat davon sind 20 Verhaltens kreativ und
das schafft es einfach nicht auf den
Einzelnen einzugehen das sind sehr gute
die geändert werden müssen wo
Handlungsbedarf steht heraflisch man
fragt sich ja wir sind ja eigentlich ein
sehr reiches Land wir sind viel zu
Weltmeister auch beim Steuerzahlen wird
das Geld falsch verteilt kommt es nicht
richtig an was passiert mit den
Steuergeldern
ja gut was die Armutsbekämpfung angeht
da haben wir uns natürlich in den
letzten Jahren sehr stark überkapaziert
auf die armenalten so das Problem der
armen alten ist natürlich da aber wenn
man es genau nimmt haben die alten in
Deutschland das geringste Armutsproblem
also die Wahrscheinlichkeit auf einen
alten in Deutschland zu treffen ist in
etwa so bei 3,13,2 Prozent die
durchschnittswahrscheinlichkeit liegt
doppelt so hoch bei 7%. die armuts
Wahrscheinlichkeit der Kinder liegt
dabei noch mal wieder doppelt so viel
das heißt Armut ist sicher nicht ein
Problem von alten Menschen das wird in
den Medien immer so entsprechend
dargestellt aber im statistischen
Jahrbuch und das wäre auch meine mediale
Empfehlung zur Literaturrecherche bei
der Sache im statistischen Jahrbuch ist
es ganz deutlich also wir haben wir
haben Armut von niedrig beziehenden
Familien mit Kindern das da ist wirklich
Armut also niedrig verdienen mit Kindern
das ist die die Armutsfalle von der
Siegelung auch sprach und das ist auch
völlig richtig
die Frage wie das Bildungssystem dann
funktioniert das was er ganz anders also
da muss man vor sich sein
tatsache ist dass wir noch nie so viele
Lehrer auf so wenig Schüler gehabt haben
wie jetzt also wenn sie in meiner
Generation gewesen sind aber waren sie
in Schulklassen deutlich anders und bei
Ihnen wahrscheinlich auch schon besser
und sehen Sie das das ist ihm halt
einfach eine Problematik die wenn man
kann Geld reinschütten ja mag sein aber
wenn das nicht nützt wenn Sie die Lehrer
verdoppeln und sie haben trotzdem nichts
dran aber bleiben wir einmal bei der bei
der Armut Herr Siegel hat ja auch gesagt
viele Menschen werden diesen Winter
hungern da würde ich gerne einmal
Alexander Kistler Fragen von der NZZ wie
du das a bewertest ob der Journalismus
darüber auch schon genug berichtet und
wie das eigentlich medial gerade
gehandhabt wird ich habe schon den
Eindruck dass der Journalismus nicht die
Augen verschließt vor den realen
Problemen der Menschen für die wir ja
auch schreiben und da sind ist ja kein
Selbstzweck wir wollen ja wahrgenommen
werden müssen wahrgenommen wir müssen
auch ernst genommen werden und ernst
genommen werden kann man nur wenn man
die Realität anerkennt und das sehe ich
eben dann schon ein Problem unserer
gegenwärtigen Regierung ich kann es ja
nicht ändern weil da hört man doch
eigentlich zwei Sätze immer der eine
heißt wir lassen niemanden zurück
siegelkurve sagen da wird jede Menge
zurückgelassen der zweite Satz ist das
fand ich mindestens genauso erschreckend
den wir immer hört wir sind gegen die
soziale Kälte soziale Kälte sind die
anderen sind CDU FDP die kalten
konservativ wir sind gegen die soziale
Kälte jetzt wird man aber offenbar die
ampelregierung der faktischen wohnlichen
Kälte wenn ich hier höre dass die
Einrichtungen die sich um die Versorgung
der Armen kümmern dass die allein
gelassen werden mit Ihrer Energiekosten
dann stimmt doch etwas nicht da muss ich
doch ganz klar sagen das ist ein
Anlaufpunkt da muss ich unterstützen
dass dort wenigstens wirklich im ganz
konkreten Sinne Wärme herrscht hier in
Berlin wird ein Netzwerk der Wärme
aufgebaut gerade so heißt das also wenn
es ganz kalt ist sollen die Leute in
Gemeindezentren kommen in Bibliotheken
um sich aufzuwärmen Frau Kiefer hat sich
da ganz toll mit so einem putzigen Logo
fotografieren lassen ich würde sagen
wenn es schon bestehende Strukturen gibt
wo man weiß dort treffen sich Arme
zusammen und elementare Bedürfnisse el
unsere Bedürfnisse stillen zu können
muss man doch die von dieser Energie
Last befreien oder ihn zumindest so
helfen dass diese Noten nicht mehr haben
also ich glaube wir verschließen nicht
die Augen ich gebe zu man hat das Bild
von den armen alten hat man oft das kann
man auch pittoresk bebildern aber wir
haben wirklich eine rentner-generation
der ist alles in allem ziemlich gut geht
da hat er Recht und jetzt aber auch
Vorsicht mit diesen medialen Geschichten
von wegen jetzt werden wir hungern jetzt
werden wir frieren und so weiter und so
fort also vorsicht also nochmal
Hysterie und Panik nutzt uns nie was das
haben wir in der corona-krise erlebt wie
Medien im Grunde genommen
müsste er einfach mal reingucken ins
Statistische Jahrbuch dann würde ich in
die Statistik gesehen die Realität ich
habe sie jeden Tag vor Augen ich habe
Kinder die haben gesagt dass Ihr Kind 5
€ zu Weihnachten bekommt maximal dann
ist das schlichtweg falsch die Kinder
setzte in der Sozialhilfe sind deutlich
höher da sind locker 5 Euro drin das ist
völliger Blödsinn was sie da erzählen
ein Kind für ein Fahrrad 50 Cent Monat
anspannen das ist das gerecht ist nicht
so dass wir die armen alleine lassen wir
haben eine Sozialhilfe für Familien mit
zwei Erwachsenen in Arbeitslosigkeit
plus zwei Kindern die liegt bei 2400
2500 Euro das muss man mal verdienen
können also es ist nicht so dass die
Armut wirklich hungern lässt oder
frieren lässt
der Gas selbst der Dieselpreis zum
Beispiel ja wenn Sie heute ein ein Liter
Diesel kaufen dann müssen sie heute nur
halb so lange für diesen Lieder Diesel
der 2 € kostet halb so lange als
Durchschnittsverdiener arbeiten wie sie
in den 70er Jahren dafür gearbeitet
haben das heißt die
erschwinglichkeitsindikatoren sind
deutlich anders und das ist das wo wir
Preise messen wir beste Preise doch
nicht in Euro sehr völliger Blödsinn
aber ein Kind zur 3,50 € für Essen zur
Verfügung hat dann verraten wenn ein
Kind Preise in Zeit wir lassen einmal
auch essen
spricht von Menschen mit denen ich jeden
Tag zu tun habe wenn ein Kind pro Tag
das von Hartz IV lebt 3,50 € für Essen
zur Verfügung hat dann ernähren sie mal
einen Menschen von 3,50 € am Tag heute
das funktioniert nicht und wenn ein Kind
50 Cent pro Monat bekommt und für ein
Fahrrad zu sparen das ständig wächst
dieses Kind wächst ständig braucht also
in sein Leben drei fahrradgrößen wie
soll denn dieses Kind das zusammen
bekommen und natürlich die Eltern
bekommen unter Umständen ihre Mietpreise
bezahlt aber Energiekosten werden sie
häufig auch mit alleinige dass sie
kriegen nicht alles bezahlt und
natürlich kriegt einen eine Bedürftige
Mutter sag mal da kommt eine
bildungsferne Mutter die geht zum
Jobcenter der Sachbearbeiter bei
sachbearbeit beim Jobcenter sagt der
Mutter nicht welche Ansprüche sie alle
hat sondern sie beantragt ihr Geld und
das bekommt sie sie hat viel mehr
Ansprüche wenn sie das nicht weiß
bekommen sie es nicht weil sie sagt
bearbeite sie gar nicht drauf Hinweis
deswegen gibt es Leute die das System
ausnutzen und andere nicht wenn neue
Pakete aufgelegt werden weiß unsere
Bundesregierung von vornherein dass nur
30 Prozent der Menschen überhaupt die
bedürftig sind diese Gelder Beantragung
das andere sparen Sie ein sie können mir
viel von Statistiken erzählen ich mache
meine Arbeitszeit 27 Jahren ich habe
Menschen sterben dafür melden auch dass
sie überlaufen sind also es wird immer
mehr Lebensmittel abgeholt und wenn
nichts mehr da ist könnt ihr auch nichts
mehr rausgeben
die Menschen haben das Geld für
Lebensmittel aus den Steuer gezahlten
Mitteln die der Staat ihnen zur
Verfügung stellt wir geben früher haben
wir ja Warenkörbe tatsächlich eine
Sozialhilfe auch definiert jeder hat das
Recht auf das was er da an Lebensmitteln
braucht und auch hier vorsichtig mit den
Lebensmitteln wir haben jetzt und hier
eine Bevölkerung die noch nie so geringe
Anteile ihres Einkommens für
Lebensmittel bezahlt haben wie jetzt wir
haben früher haben wir haben wir in den
60 70 Jahren haben wir im Grunde einen
regen gehabt dass ein Drittel Miete ein
Drittel Lebensmittel und ein Drittel
sonst
heute zahlen Sie für Lebensmittel man
gerade mal zehn Prozent und für die
Miete mal gerade 20%
sind besser sie haben sich verbessert ja
die Lebensmittelpreise sehr gestiegen
also das sagen ja jetzt die letzten
Jahre ja ein zwei Jahre genau aber wenn
sie es langfristig vergleichen
aber fragen wir einmal Frau Obert
wahrscheinlich etwas schwierig bei Ihrem
Lifestyle das Thema aber also ich weiß
sehr wohl die Linke Grenze und die
rechte Grenze und ich muss im Moment
auch mehr schrubben damit ich sehen kann
dass alles klappt und ich sehe auch
viele Leute in der Praxis und ich muss
Ihnen recht geben ja ich weiß nicht was
das alles für Statistiken sind ich
glaube keiner Statistik die du nicht
selbst gefälscht hast und
den liebt dich sowieso ist ja jetzt egal
was gesagt hat aber wenn du auf die
Straße guckst wenn du mit der U-Bahn
fährst es sind und ich sage ja ich habe
auch es ist verhalten viele Kinder weil
sie aus irgendwelchen komischen
Verhältnissen kommen es ist nicht nur so
dass dass die nicht irgendwie nett und
adrett gekleidet sind und einen neuen
Schulranzen haben ja aber und ich tue
auch ein bisschen was wasch Charity
angeht möchte ich jetzt nicht drüber
reden aber ein Staat der die Milliarden
im Stundentakt zum Fenster rauswirft und
nicht die Millionen ja der schafft es
nicht dass die eigenen Kinder und diese
Tante Werbung die durch die ganze Welt
reist und unsere Kohle zum Fenster
rauswirft das ist nicht immer besser
geht ja kann man nicht die eigenen
Kinder hier Schulen dass die Bildung
kriegen irgendeine hat im Fernsehen call
die haben alle kein Schulranzen ja dann
gib ihnen einen Schulranzen die hat ja
die Kohle die sitzen an der Macht und
bevor 100 Milliarden fürs Militär gehen
ja Sondervermögen hier 20 Milliarden
Sondervermögen da wenn ich ich muss dich
auf Punkt
Sondervermögen für Kinderarmut
unsere Kinder wenn die häuten Problem
haben dann haben und das lösen wir nicht
ich habe Gott sei Dank keine da immer
kein Schaden angerichtet aber unsere
Kinder wenn die häuten Problem haben die
haben das Problem für immer wenn wir da
nicht helfen alle unsere Kinder hat ja
schon wenig rechnen
aber alle die ein Problem haben die
Kinder die also wirklich hungern ja und
es liegt vielleicht auch nicht nur dran
dass die Mütter kein Geld haben sondern
das ist nicht gebacken kriegen die
Fürsorge für die Kinder und das ist
vielleicht noch viel viel wichtiger ich
meine meine Mutter hat jeden Kuchen
selber gebacken jeden Berliner alles und
es war kostengünstig aber ich glaube
dass diese Frauen die da in diesem wo
sie einfach knapp sind mit Geld nicht so
können ja also ich würde da die Menschen
nicht einfach über einen Kamm scheren
wir haben ein großes Problem an unserer
Gesellschaft das ist auch die
Mittelschicht die auch merkt dass alles
teurer wird die immer mehr
zusammenbricht und ich spreche nicht von
Unternehmen mit 1000 Mitarbeitern wir
haben viele Spender davon müssen wir
eben an an Summe der Menschen die haben
allein in diesem Jahr 1500 Menschen
verloren aus der Mittelschicht die uns
im Monat 2025 Euro gespendet haben die
sagen wir können uns das schlichtweg
nicht mehr leisten mir erzählt niemand
in diesem Land dass wir genug Geld in
der Tasche haben und dass die Armut
nicht immer mehr um sich greift das muss
man nicht über Statistiken gucken da
gucke ich mir die Menschen an der gehe
ich raus auf die Straße da sehe ich wie
selbst die die großen Konzerne die
Lebensmittelgeschäfte kaufen immer
weniger Waren an weil die Kaufkraft
nicht da ist deswegen haben die Tafeln
doch auch gar nicht Lebensmittel mehr es
wird weniger weggeworfen weil weniger
gekauft wird und den Menschen geht es in
unserem Land schlechter und die
abgehängten Kinder und wir sie sprechen
von einem Bildungssystem wo genug Lehrer
da sind gehen Sie mal an einen
Ballungsgebiet wie Berlin Hellersdorf
Neukölln oder sonst was da haben sie
einen Lehrer da haben sie keinen
Erzieher noch mit in der Klasse wie in
den besser gestellten Gebieten da ist
der Lehrer alleine der hat gar keine
Unterstützung da ist die Krankheitsrate
der Lehrer unter Umständen bei 50% da
gibt es einen Unterrichtsausfall das
gravierend weil die Lehrer alle
psychisch erkranken weil sie eben mit
diesen massenweise von Problemen zu tun
haben es fehlen in unserem Land
Vertrauenspersonen die sich um die
Menschen kümmern die Hilfe brauchen das
hatten wir früher in unseren Schulen
gehabt da ging es uns besser da hat
Bildung auch kein Geld in dem Sinne
gekostet ich musste keine
Schulmaterialien bezahlen ich komme auch
aus der tiefsten Armut ich komme von
ganz unten und aber das die Bildung hat
funktioniert ich habe die Möglichkeit
gehabt aus vielen Ausbildungsplätzen zu
wählen das hat man heute nicht weil die
Ansprüche für unsere Kinder sind häufig
da du musst Abitur haben wenn man heute
nur mittlere reif hat oder so wird man
schon komisch angerufen Fehler und wer
fördert denn unsere Kinder wer erkennt
ja die Potenziale unsere Kinder wenn
keine Vertrauensperson da sind und
allein anziehende Müttern von den
Menschen von denen sie reden die in
Armut sind die sind doch in unserer
Gesellschaft allgemein gelassen wer
ergreift denn das Wort für Sie wer wer
unterstützt sie denn wer kennt sie denn
in der Politik kennt sie keine also Wort
ergreifen sehr viele für Sie ob Sie das
Richtige tun ist die Frage ob Sie das
richtige sagen genau also ich kenne jede
Menge jeden Tag werden Vorträge gehalten
von Parteien links der Mitte vor allem
dass es sich um jeden einzelnen kümmern
und es ist faktisch nicht so genau so
ist das unbestritten ist Herr siegelko
kümmert sich sehr gut um Kinder und
kämpfe das Thema schauen Sie doch mal
bei der Arche vorbei